♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE RUSSIA HOAX IS
NOW UNRAVELING AS MUCH AS EVER
AND THE DEEP STATE IS ON THE
DEFENSIVE.
FRIDAY SANDRA LINDSEY GRAHAM,
SOUTH CAROLINA, HIS JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE RELEASED DECLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS SHOWING WHAT WE HAD
BEEN REPORTING.
THE FBI NOT ONLY HAD SERIOUS
DOUBTS ABOUT THE CLAIMS MADE IN
CHRISTOPHER STEELE’S DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER OF
MISINFORMATION THAT HILLARY PAID
FOR.
BY THE WAY, WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS HAS ITS TIME
FOR INDICTMENTS.
HE’S RIGHT.
THE TIME IS COMING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WELL, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE EXPECT INDICTMENTS.
I KNOW I EXPECT INDICTMENTS
BASED ON THE EVIDENCE I’M SEEN.
LINDSEY GRAHAM DID A GOOD JOB
EATING THAT OUT.
YOU’RE GOING TO SEE A COUPLE
OTHER DOCUMENTS COME OUT IN THE
COMING DAYS THAT WILL SUGGEST
THAT NOT ONLY WAS THE CAMPAIGN
SPIED ON BY THE FBI DID NOT ACT
APPROPRIATELY, AS THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING.
>> Sean: REMEMBER WE NOW KNOW
THAT BY EARLY 2017 THE FBI KNEW
WITHOUT ANY DOUBT WHATSOEVER
THAT DOSSIER HILLARY PAID FOR
WITH RUSSIAN LIES AND COMEY,
McCABE, THE REST OF THE
DEEP STATE, THEY KEPT USING IT
FOR ONE SIZE APPLICATION AFTER
ANOTHER.
THEY KNEW IT WAS FALSE,
PREMEDITATED FRAUD.
NOW WE LEARN FRIDAY PETER STRZOK
APPEARS TO HAVE REALIZED WELL,
DEEP STATE DAY OF RECKONING WAS
ON THE HORIZON AS THE DISGRACED
FBI AGENT LASHING OUT THROUGH
HIS LAWYER AND SENATOR GRAHAM
FOLLOWING THE LATEST
REVELATIONS.
HERE WITH MOORE,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
YOU KNOW, SENATOR, I GUESS WE
KNOW THEY WERE WARNED BEFORE THE
FIRST FISA APPLICATION.
WE KNOW McCABE SAID WITHOUT
THE DIRTY DOSSIER THERE WOULD BE
NO FISA WARRANT ISSUED.
BUT HE SAID THAT TO THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE.
NOW WE KNOW KATHLEEN KAVALEC, WE
KNOW BRUCE OHR WARNED THEM
BEFORE THE FIRST ONE.
THEY SIGNED IT.
THEN WE HAD A SUB SOURCE IN
JANUARY SAYING NO, THAT WAS ALL
BARN TALK.
YOU HAVE A NEW DOCUMENT MOSTLY
UNREDACTED.
TOO MANY REDACTIONS FOR MY
LIKING.
TELL US WHAT YOU FOUND.
>> I FOUND A MEMO THAT WAS PUT
TOGETHER AFTER THE INTERVIEW
WITH THE RUSSIAN SUB SOURCE.
YOU SAID IT WELL, SEAN PENN
WITHOUT THE RUSSIAN DOSSIER,
THEY COULDN’T OBTAIN A
WARNING.
THEY TRIED TO GET A FISA WARRANT
AGAINST CARTER PAGE AND IT WAS
REJECTED.
THEY FIND THE DOSSIER AND ALL OF
A SUDDEN THEY GET A WARRANT.
HORWITZ SAID WITHOUT THE DOSSIER
THERE’S NO WARRANT.
SO FROM JANUARY 24TH TO TEN OR
27TH THE FBI INTERVIEWS THE
RUSSIAN SUB SOURCE WHO PUT THE
DOSSIER TOGETHER.
THEY CREATED A 40 PAGE MEMO
SHOWING IT WAS A BUNCH OF
GARBAGE, NOT RELIABLE AT ALL.
HERE’S THE QUESTION.
HOW COULD IT BE THEY CONTINUE TO
USE THE DOSSIER IN APRIL AND
JUNE OF 2017 KNOWING THAT IN
JANUARY, THE DOSSIER WAS
COMPLETELY DISCREDITED BY THE
PERSON WHO PUT IT TOGETHER?
HERE IS THE QUESTION FOR ME.
DID THE INTEL ANALYST WHO WROTE
THE MEMO TELL ANYBODY OF THE
CHAIN, ALL BY THE WAY OUR CASE
JUST FELL APART?
I FIND IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
BELIEVE THAT SENIOR PEOPLE AT
THE FBI WERE NOT TOLD IN JANUARY
APART AGAINST CARTER PAGE.
>> Sean: IF THAT’S THE CASE,
NOW I DON’T KNOW.
YOU ARE THE ATTORNEY, LINDSEY,
BUT THAT CONFIRMS COMPLETELY
EVEN STRZOK NEW BUT THEY DID IT
ANYWAY.
WHAT HAPPENS TO AMERICANS WHEN
THEY LIE TO A COURT AND THEY
KNOW THEY’RE LYING TO A COURT?
>> YOU SHOULD GO TO JAIL.
TO GET A WARRANT, THE COURT
RELIES ON AFFIDAVITS SIGNED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
AUGUST 5, CALLING SALLY YATES.
SHE WAS THE NUMBER TWO AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
ON AUGUST 5TH, SHE WILL COME
BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE AND I
APPRECIATE HER VOLUNTARILY
COMING.
REMEMBER ON JANUARY 4TH, 2017,
THE FBI AGENTS INVOLVED ON THE
GROUND SAID LET’S DROP FLYNN
FROM CROSSFIRE HURRICANE.
FOUND NO EVIDENCE HE WAS WORKING
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
LET’S TAKE THEM OUT OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT’S WHEN STRZOK TELLS THOSE
PEOPLE THEY WANT TO KEEP GOING.
JANUARY 5TH THEY MEET WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN TO CONTINUE
TO SURVEIL GENERAL FLYNN.
HERE’S WHAT’S SHOCKING.
SALLY YATES, THE NUMBER TWO AT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, DID NOT
EVEN KNOW THEY WERE FOLLOWING
FLYNN BUT OBAMA DID.
HERE’S THREE THINGS I WANT TO
ASK HER.
IF YOU KNEW THEN WHAT YOU KNOW
NOW WOULD YOU HAVE SIGNED THE
WARRANT APPLICATION AGAINST
CARTER PAGE?
DID YOU HEAR JOE BIDEN SAY WHAT
ABOUT THE LOGAN ACT WHEN IT
COMES TO GENERAL FLYNN?
AND IS IT TRUE THAT YOU WERE
SURPRISED THE PRESIDENT KNEW
ABOUT THE SURVEILLANCE OF FLYNN
AND YOU DID NOT?
>> Sean: WE ALREADY KNOW THE
ANSWERS TO ALL THOSE,
SENATOR GRAHAM.
HERE’S THE NEXT STEP IN ALL
THIS.
>> WE HAVEN’T HEARD IT YET.
>> Sean: OKAY BUT WE ALREADY
KNOW WHAT WE KNEW ABOUT THE
JANUARY 5TH MEETING.
>> SHE HASN’T TESTIFIED IN
PERSON BUT SHE WILL SOON.
>> Sean: I’M TOLD THAT WE NOW
BELIEVE WE HAVE FOUND NOT ONLY
THE PERSON THAT WAS THE MAIN
SOURCE FOR THE DIRTY RUSSIAN
STEELE DOSSIER, YOU’RE SMILING.
THAT MEANS I’M PROBABLY OVER THE
TARGET.
AND I’VE ALSO HEARD THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE GOOD, THE
99% WITHIN THE FBI COMMUNITY,
THE WORLD’S PREMIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, AND THE
CIA, THE WORLD’S PREMIER
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
I DO NINE OF GOOD PEOPLE.
THEY ARE NOW BEGINNING TO TALK
AND THEY ARE BEGINNING TO TELL
ABOUT STORIES THAT THEY WARNED
EVERYBODY NOT TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS, AND THEY WERE IGNORED,
WHICH MEANS THAT’S EVEN WORSE
THAN WE THOUGHT.
>> THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN.
PEOPLE ARE BEGINNING TO TALK TO
REMEMBER IN THE AFFIDAVIT,
SOMEBODY TOLD THE COURT THE SUB
SOURCE, THE RUSSIAN GUY WAS
TRUTHFUL AND COOPERATIVE.
NOTHING COULD HAVE BEEN MORE
UNTRUE THAN THAT.
HE WAS TRUTHFUL BUT HE DESTROYED
THE RELIABILITY OF THE DOSSIER.
THEY MISLED THE COURT.
IF YOU CAN FIND THE PERSON WHO
SAID THAT, YOU’RE OFF TO THE
RACES.
IT’S IMPOSSIBLE THEY WROTE THIS
40 PAGE MEMO AND DIDN’T SHARE IT
WITH PEOPLE OF THE TOP.
HERE’S WHAT PETER STRZOK SAID IN
FEBRUARY 2017.
AGAIN, WE ARE UNAWARE OF ANY
TRUMP ADVISORS ENGAGING IN
CONVERSATION WITH RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS.
THIS IS IN FEBRUARY 2017.
HERE’S THE QUESTION.
WHY THE HELL WAS MUELLER A POINT
TO BEGIN WITH THE THIN FEBRUARY
THEY HAD NO EVIDENCE OF TROUBLE
OFFICIALS TALKING TO THE
RUSSIANS, WORKING WITH THEM.
WHAT HAPPENED BETWEEN FEBRUARY
AND MAY OF 2017?
>> Sean: LINDSEY GRAHAM PAID
BY THE WAY, I’M SO SORRY TO HEAR
HEAR.
I KNOW ROSIE O’DONNELL AND
BARBRA STREISAND AND
HILLARY CLINTON DONATED MILLIONS
TO YOUR OPPONENT.
I KNOW THE PEOPLE OF
SOUTH CAROLINA ARE GOING TO BE
VERY INFLUENCED BY THE MILLIONS
OF BARBRA STREISAND AND ROSIE
AND HELLER.
I’M REALLY WORRIED ABOUT THAT